with us in Arizona
hi Daniel how are you I'm good how are
you David Chrissie better than we
deserved for sure so I am a college
student studying mechanical engineering
I am a rising junior and I have a
scholarship that pays for most of my
college I'm still a little bit
financially depending on my parents and
I'm just wondering what I should be
doing with my money right now the best
set myself up for the future okay
why does my screen say conflicting
advice from family and that has nothing
to do with your question I I do receive
a lot of information from say my parents
friends other family I just kind of want
to clarify like a good clarification of
what I should do what do you think you
should do I mean my gut tells me just to
stack my money up for my part-time job
as high as I can until I get out of
college but a lot of other people say oh
you need to put in a Roth IRA you need
to get a secure credit card and put in
mutual funds like you say so I just kind
of want that clarification okay all
right so what what I want you to do is
not do what anyone says me included I
want you to think through what makes
sense and if they can make a case for
their argument and your thought pattern
says I'm learning from that person I'm
gonna do that then you could go with
that that becomes your decision but you
don't need to do well your crazy uncle
said to do or your dad said to do or
Dave Ramsey said Christie said to do
just because we said it you need to do
it because you understood it it makes
sense and you implement it so our
argument would be and you've obviously
heard it before because you parroted it
back to us to pile up cash to get you
out of school so when you heard us say
that why do we say that I heard a
similar story over the college did it
just to both save up for like an
emergency fund but also just to avoid
debt is
as possible okay well here's the deal
Daniel the amount of money that you
invest how much money we're talking
about investing currently I have about
thirty five hundred left in this junior
and senior year but I currently have no
money to invest right now so let's say
about let's just pick a number let's say
you invested ten thousand dollars for
two years and you made a 10% rate of
return for those two years I'd be a
thousand dollars a year for two years
for two thousand dollars does that sound
right yes or you kept that $10,000 in a
pile to ensure that Daniel graduates
with a degree without any debt in
mechanical engineering dude
mechanical engineering on one hand
$2,000 in the other hand I'll take
mechanical engineering rate of return
ding ding much higher Daniel is a better
investment than mutual funds I guess
you're a and I guess I like to follow up
and I guess I in my gut I already knew
that but when would you say is like a
good time to start on like those mutual
funds they're like those endeavors to
make myself passive income after you
graduate yeah you're trying to get into
the real world Daniel so like that this
pile of cash is we were just talking
about this it's the peace of mind of the
expenses you're gonna incur from
graduating to finding a place to live to
figuring out a job there's just going to
be expenses as you transition to being
independent the other thing I would
throw out there you mentioned when you
very first ask the question that you're
still financially dependent on your
parents I would just say that since you
are connected to them financially let's
have a conversation with your parents
about expectations what are the
expectations of the amount of money
they're giving you in this season of
being a college what what's the
expectation of what you're doing with
your money because if they're expecting
that you're working because you're going
to offset your expenses that's different
than you're working and you're going to
save it up and you all agree on that so
just just make sure that there's a
conversation there about expectations
while you're in school and they're there
funding you here's the thing folks
Daniel included if you make a decision
and you know why you made the decision
then when
other people have opinions you suddenly
go you don't have a vote this is my life
and but if you make a decision because
someone told you to then someone else
comes along and tells you to make a
different decision then you're going to
constantly be running back and forth and
back and forth across the road until you
finally get hit by a car and so you you
you need to really know why you're doing
something and that's why we tell people
to never invest for instance unless
you're doing that with someone with a
heart of a teacher but instead people go
and they invest with someone and they
trust the person to do all the thinking
for them and then they say that
investment broker lost all my money no
you did you were stupid you lost all
your money because you didn't think for
yourself you didn't take the time to
learn and in about investing that's an
example and so or they say well you know
I I just did what this guy said and then
I can't sleep at night well that's
because you don't know what you're doing
if you bother to learn what you're doing
it gives you a sense of confidence
Christie you talk so much about
confidence and confidence and competence
are tied together yeah and it's
interesting cuz we also talk about the
different what leads to confidence one
of it one piece of it is information
they're saying you go do your homework
you figure out why and understand it
there's information of understanding the
why there's also it's amazing how when
whatever once we understand are why you
do you are able to withstand peer
pressure and other people's opinions cuz
you're like no this is why I'm doing it
I don't care what you think I don't care
what you say because I understand I've
done my homework this is what I'm doing
and this is why I'm doing it and you
don't get a vote the way that you said
it I've got a friend as a PhD in
economics from Cambridge this guy's
smart and every time we're having dinner
and we started talking about he goes
grams you don't ball money said no no
borrow money you're like are we here
again every time I'm with him and he's
just he's baffled he cannot possibly
grasp the idea yeah and he's so
condescending but he's really smile yeah
and he rolls his eyes and the eye roll
is the worst condensation right
you know and I'm just like dude you're a
dinner that does not give you a vote you
got a PhD and you still hadn't figured
this out no I don't borrow money and so
when there's a covetous oppression I'm
not over here sweating in my boots like
you with your broke self and your PhD
right you know so come at me I mean but
you know I'm real comfortable and why
I'm doing this like as comfortable as
anybody you'll ever meet obviously so
you you know when you get comfortable in
why you're doing something because you
have the information and a sense of
confidence in the information and I'm
making a decision based on this then
when your Uncle Henry with an attitude
right has an opinion that Thanksgiving
dinner
then you can be nice to him and kind and
just walk out there and going that's not
going right right yeah and it comes from
two different places too there's there's
some things like we teach in money here
are the baby steps you're the best
practices here is the path to win with
money and there's some things and I've
seen you get calls like this Dave where
it's kind of like you turn it back to
them what do you want to do what's right
for you and people so off it like tell
me what to do tell me what you like we
could do this or this it's your life
what do you want to do and and when you
start to figure out what do you want to
do what's your goals what's your version
of success what's right for you your
family your dreams your future and then
you develop confidence in that you're
able to withstand Uncle Henry or whoever
the peer pressure because like now it's
my life you want to parent your kids
different go on ahead you got kids your
this is my kids is how I'm gonna do it
this I'm gonna live my life these are my
goals it just gives you more of a ground
to stand on in your own life which by
the way you got it's your life that's
the deal